Life made Anton became a blogger.
He lives in a water-company
housing compound miles from anywhere,
in a tiny village that doesn’t even have a name.
But he’s convinced that soon,
all that will change.
Every day of the week,
the Khoroshevs are up at 6 am to milk the cows.
Anton’s mother isn’t just a crypto-currency expert.
After some convincing she’s become a kind of a technical expert for the blog.
Her specialist areas are how to
help cows when they’re calving,
or choosing the best plants for your garden.
And this is Anton's muse and collaborator,
his wife, Alevtina.
A few recent comments on the blog suggested
that Alevtina doesn’t always wear
particularly elegant clothing!
That’s the price of publicity.
They need to post at least two new videos
every week to ensure
that the blog doesn’t lose subscribers.
That means filming something every day.
You might wonder where news comes
from in the country!
After all, there are only 4 houses in the village,
and nothing ever happens.
But the young couple is determined to move.
That’s why they started the blog,
to raise enough for a new house because
they could never start
a farm here in this temporary home.
Even though they never studied public relations,
Anton and Alevtina intuitively
knew never to ignore subscriber questions.
Despite being exhausted,
at night they shoot videos to answer their viewers.
Half the population of the unnamed village works
at the sewage plant.
And they’ve all been called in to work
because of a night-time accident.
Neighbours find it hard to understand
what makes the Khoroshevs’
so special that people all over the country
and the world want to watch videos about them.
But when there was an emergency,
it wasn’t the police or TV news they called,
but Anton, to discuss the problem in his blog.
But the Khoroshevs are edging closer to their dream.
The blog now makes around
a thousand dollars a month,
and that means they can start
saving for the house they want.
The Village Family vlog already has more
than 150,000 worldwide subscribers.
The new technology changed village life.
Mobile phone is still awful,
but a Wi-Fi is available even in the cowshed.
Six months have passed
and we’re back with the Khoroshevs.
They’ve finally bought the house of their dreams,
and soon, the long awaited move will at last take place.
They found two suitable houses with enough land for a shared farm in Volgograd area,
but the Khoroshevs still unsure if they’d can start a farm with the Germans who,
moved to Russia after watching the blog.
Everyone’s busy making their own decisions
but the biggest challenge is still to come:
moving with all the cattle and starting a farm in a new location.
But Anton’s mother has refused to swap Stavropol Area
for Volgograd region.
The family will have to split up.
They’re about to leave
and all that remains is to get the cows into the truck,
an operation that looks a lot like a rodeo.
They might be exhausted after the trip
but the blog still needs updating with new videos,
because now, a new dream
has appeared on the horizon:
a real farm,
and they need to earn more money to buy it.